SCP-682 Vs SCP-524. The Hard to Destroy
Reptile Vs The cuddly wittle bunny named Walter
that can eat pretty much everything.
Does 682 look enough like a big,
angry carrot for Walter to get the job done?
682 regarded Walter with suspicion
as the bunny approached. It then
began gnawing through 682’s leg, causing
the giant monster to bellow and flee.
He chased 682 around the containment chamber
for several minutes, before 682 tapped out.
682 climbed up the wall of
the test chamber and waited,
while Walter washed his face with his
paws. 524 then began chewing his way
through the wall of the test chamber, at
which point, the experiment was aborted.
Still, very good try, little buddy.